welcome to this video playing grimaces
what italic here the ICC five-minute
pool yeah that's that's a game that
counts if I somehow managed to win that
I'm going to have my all-time high with
the chess explain account so keep things
crossed but italic is not not exactly
the easiest opponent is really a good
player so he's playing the Kings Indian
it's kind of surprising I wasn't really
thinking he's a king's indian guy
interesting i did not really expect that
but anyway it would be interesting to
play playing this 92 line that i
recently experimented with a bit okay
this is a very this a conservative way
to play it with c5 just trying to to
block the Queen side and ma'am I have a
vague idea how this is continuing black
can go a five if he wants or start with
this yep to take and night be three I
think this is how it is done and five
this Bishop g5 them I am okay yeah there
are those kind of ideas who I wonder
still play 95 here at Bishop g5
yeah probably does not hurt um let's
think about this for a moment Bishop h4s
probably probably a weird idea
should be three f5f three I don't know
until you take 52 f5 can shake and play
afford this kind of thing yeah that's
really hey I as mentioned i was mostly
experimenting with this oh he's not he's
going for something else entirely
interesting for bishop age six it seems
what about f forces an idea let's try
that as mentioned i'm kind of making
things up as I go along okay
hmm
interesting way to play with huge
tension in the center I actually
actually didn't take that into account
he can take a for him and I cannot
capture because of my undefended knight
on c3 hmm that's not that's not too
great okay let's see maybe you can take
a point to just play g500 or that
ok
we're thinking that nitrous e6 might be
interesting now but maybe he has some
concrete ways to play him check like
this checking at night g4 or something I
am Not sure
ok so we woke you will go night you form
it let's see him I have to go there
anyway what whatever ok so how dangerous
is all is that kind of thing not quite
sure actually if I check that yes a
chick with a pawn
let's see I'm absolutely not sure about
this position it might be good for him
but it is it is very tricky so.2d 30 to
f3 mm-hmm anything else can I get to
give for I don't think so it's yep so
cookware see one
is difficult
maybe you can just go just paid you for
you I was thinking to take and play
rupee six what he has Queen edge for it
then again I would just take it what
let's just play it and hope it works
okay that i did not see
time warning to cannot take anywhere
there
tonight f2 then mm-hmm might have to to
check if form okay I'm just continuing
because of my chance auction or the
highest possible rating with getting
that game would be embarrassing anyway
okay he totally killed me him right
person what a howler yeah I'm not sure
him here I don't this shouldn't be that
bad right this is that bad cannot
believe that I think it's just too
complicated for my brain so maybe see 50
km a computer actually likes that but it
doesn't like that move so look b7 why
it's super complicated of course I
shouldn't have allowed this this this
this general thing here after f5
allowing allowing this thing or maybe I
should have taken on f4 with the rook I
mean it's possible now this is this is
definitely a better move that covers
Kavis III and not and now enter this
whole business there with the with g5
it's very very tricky to play
computer still loves white yeah but I
don't get it h fri what move is that i
have no idea check this looks far more
human to me no this sir yeah i took you
just outplayed me them okay well thanks
for watching